hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts measurement of
pesticides in cannabis presented by
Jeffrey Dahl application scientist at
Siobhan zoo I'm Alexis Krause of
leopards and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presence by laberd's laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at I mean time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit please join me and welcoming dr.
Dahl I will now turn the presentation
over to him
hello and welcome to this presentation
it's my pleasure to present for you
and the topic of today's talk is
measuring pesticides in cannabis and the
techniques that we're going to talk
about our industry standard for
measuring pesticides in food and
vegetables and now we're applying those
same techniques with the appropriate
modifications to cannabis
so as everyone knows the cannabis
industry in the United States has really
taken off in the last few years and many
states have rolled out either medical or
medical and recreational programs and
the support of that testing is required
for a variety of analytes in a sample
potency measurements are used to
determine the amounts of the
cannabinoids in the sample which could
vary from strain to strain residual
solvent testing is required for prepared
products to make sure that any residual
pressing chemicals the solvents that
were used to extract the cannabinoids
are no longer present and those would be
used for cannabinoid concentrates
microbiology testing is used to make
sure that the products haven't spoiled
heavy metals testing is used to make
sure that the plants haven't bent become
contaminated with different types of
harmful metals such as mercury arsenic
terpene measurements are used to profile
the flavor and the chemical attributes
of the strain and finally pesticide
testing is required to make sure that
the products aren't going to cause
consumers any health problems
cannabis is a
dollar value crop and there's a high
risk of mold or insect attack especially
when it's grown indoors because of the
moisture levels but also outdoors since
it's more open to the environment and
it's easy for insects to come in and
obviously once an infestation takes hold
either of insects or mold the crop is
ruined and a lot of money is wasted so
farmers conventional farmers who grow
fruits and vegetables but also cannabis
farmers want to protect their crops and
frequently pesticides are applied in
order to prevent that however from the
consumer point of view pesticides really
haven't been tested in cannabis and
they've not been approved for use for
cannabis so from the consumer standpoint
there's a really unknown variable which
is how will smoking cannabis that's been
sprayed with pesticides affect the
consumer
have adopted different regulations for
pesticide testing in cannabis Colorado
Nevada Oregon Washington California have
all adopted regulations for cannabis
testing and in each of those states and
others cannabis testing labs have been
established and accredited by the states
and they've already started testing
products in many states and
the rules pertaining to that have been
NAC
have been rolled out in phases first the
regulations are proposed then they're
adopted and then finally enforced and
each of those states however has adopted
a slightly different monitoring list and
so this for us represents a continuously
changing problem but luckily due to our
methods we're able to add in and change
the methods to adopt the state
requirements so for example these four
documents show the state monitoring
lists from Oregon state Nevada
Washington State and Colorado
California's also come out with their
lists as well as Canada and many other
states as well
so lc-ms is the main technique that we
use for pesticides because it's severe
robust it can detect the widest range of
analytes and it'll be the focus of this
presentation today however depending on
which pesticide requirements a lab is
following they may need to add GCMs as
well and gc/ms is particularly well
suited for certain analytes typically
the older pesticides which are not used
much anymore but depending on the
state's requirements the GCMs may be
needed to meet all the state's
requirements but it varies from state to
state
you
so in our present method which is an L
CMS based method we first start out with
a representative test portion and the
typical test portion is one or one and a
half grams of dried flower the first
step of the sample preparation is to
imagine eyes the sample and what this
does is it allows us to select a
representative amount as well as brined
up to plant material which will allow
the pesticides to be extracted more
easily if the pesticide was incorporated
into the plant matrix and we didn't rind
up the sample then it might happen that
the pesticides could be in the product
but not detected so it's important to
grind up the sample to release the
pesticides from the plant matrix so for
grinding we investigated several
different techniques for grinding and
our criteria to get the best result was
to find out the grinding method which
gives us a uniform homogeneous and small
particle size but we'll having high
throughput and being easy to use so
displayed here are the several methods
of grinding that we investigated the
herb grinder is the typical grinding we
tested a handheld and Majin Iser a
coffee grinder a tissue Lizer which is a
consists of Teflon grinding jars with a
grinding ball inside the genome grinder
the magic bullet and a flax mill so we
found that the herb grinder gave a
particle size that was too coarse
it was very uniform but the when the
particles aren't small enough the
pesticide extraction might be
inefficient we found the handheld
imagine Iser became clogged very easily
and it was time-consuming to clean the
coffee grinder gave a very excellent
very fine particle size and homogeneous
but typically was better suited for
larger sample volumes so depending on
the state's rules this might be a
suitable option
the tissue Eliezer gave also a very fine
powder but this is more difficult to
clean since the grinding jars have to be
cleaned it between each sample finally
we found that the Gino grinder was the
best choice because it gives a very fine
homogeneous particle size but also has
very high throughput since it doesn't
require cleaning the grinding jar with
every sample so for this presentation we
use the genome grinder
so after grunting the sample we need to
extract the pesticides with a solvent
extraction and we found after testing a
variety of techniques that a solvent
extraction is the best and our solvent
extraction starts with one gram of
powdered sample and we extract that with
acidified a CD nitrile with shaking and
modernization and sonication also is a
good way to help extract pesticides this
solvent after extracting the best sides
out will spin the sample down in a
centrifuge and this will allow the plant
material that remains to pellet in the
bottom and then we'll take the
supernatant which is the co natural
extract to the next stage of the
analysis
and this slide shows an example of how
that looks on the left you see the flour
sample in the middle after being ground
up in the Gino grinder with two steel
balls and then finally on the right is
the solvent extracted sample
now we could inject this directly into
the instrument however in order to keep
the instrument cleaner we like to do a
cleanup step and the cleanup step
involves taking the sample extract and
subjecting it to a cleanup treatment
with the material which is called
dispersive SPE and SPE is the solid
phase extraction and this consists of
several ingredients which designed to
adsorb the matrix that is the undesired
compound in the sample in this case we
trusted several different formulas that
consist of PSA that's the primary
secondary amine GCB is a graphic eyes
carbon black and c teen as the optical
silane material and in different ratios
so we found that if the cleanup was too
strong such as formula 2 we lose too
many pesticides so we selected a formula
1 which is a lower amount of carbon and
that gives us good recovery of
pesticides while removing a lot of the
matrix components that we don't want so
this is a fairly fast cleanup and it's
only needed to shake the sample with
this powder and then spin it down again
and take the supernatant and directly
inject for analysis
for our present analysis we use the LCM
SAT 50 triple quadrupole mass
spectrometer we make several different
models depending on how low of a
detection limits are required for labs
needs so we also have a more sensitive
lcms 80/60 and also several more
entry-level models and this is this is
the instrument used in the present
analysis
so our sample is injected onto an LC
column and our separation is performed
and the pesticides will elute with an
expected retention time and an example
from a de gram as shown in this figure
and for each analyte we detect its
presence by using the Machine settings
in mrm mode and we've optimized the M
REMS for each analyte to get the maximum
signal and we've also adjusted the
chromatography to give us good
separation between the interfering
components and the analytes of interest
so using this method we prepared
calibration curves this is just a
representative selection of several
important analytes down to the typical
required detection limits in various
states and we're showing linear results
for all these analytes
next to further validate our method we
analyze triplicate samples for our
calibration curves and this is showing
the rsd of those triplicates in the in a
wide concentration range to be well
below 20% so it's showing that we have
very good reproducibility
and next we're showing the replicates
for the QC samples the quality control
samples are used to verify the methods
accuracy and what we're showing here is
for the three different spiking levels
of QC s just showing the 50 man gram per
gram level and we're showing the rsd is
well below 20 percent in three different
strains
actually show the recovery and the
recovery is important so that we know
that we are not losing the analyte in
the extraction process and for nearly
all the compounds we have recovery book
between seventy one hundred and twenty
percent
next in order to determine whether or
not there might be any strain specific
problems with the analysis we analyzed
several difference all the compounds in
several different strains and you can
see here that in each of those strains
we get a similar result and that
indicates that the method performance is
very good even using different strains
of cannabis
and just if anyone's interested for this
analysis we used one strain was a Dutch
treat one strain was orange push and
there was a third strain that was
composed of a composite of several
different strains
so this is our analyte list for the
present method and this is well below
the required detection limits for
various states and this list actually is
much longer than is required for
California Oregon and even Canada
so next we've taken our validated method
and run real samples that we obtained
from the market in a blind selection
process and in this case we've selected
27 dry flour samples from Washington
State and used our method to detect how
many samples actually contain pesticides
and this analysis was done about twelve
or sixteen months ago and we have found
actually of someone higher than expected
rate of positives from some of these
samples some of the more recent ones are
less less positive but for these for the
sample set we detected pesticides and
about half of the samples the most
commonly detective is pepper no beet
oxide and this is a pesticide that's
used in combination actually with the
pyrethrins which don't often survive due
to oxidation and error if we remove
those and actually the positive rates
only about 25%
and we can also see several pesticides
we detected that were not on the state
monitoring Liz
so next we show the results for the
cannabis concentrates
so cannabis concentrates of course can
be prepared from cannabis material using
several different methods some of them
are co2 extractions some of them are
solvent extractions and some of them are
using propane butane extractions and
depending on the extraction conditions
these may be carrying over the
pesticides that were originally in the
plant material into the finished product
and in fact due to the concentrating
effect of the solvent not only does it
concentrate the desired cannabinoids but
it might also concentrate the pesticides
as well so we selected a range of
concentrates the top row in the pictures
are showing shatters and the middle row
is sort of waxes and the bottom row are
more oils on the right side of the
screen is a vape pen and we've tested a
quite a wide range of these types of
concentrates we also tested a wide range
of other types of concentrates and
there's various pills and powders and
oils this is a representative selection
of what we tested
so the first step in the analysis is to
dissolve the sample so we found after
doing a dissolution test that methanol
was the most effective solvent and for
nearly all of the different types of
concentrates we found methanol was very
good at dissolving all the cannabinoids
and all and all the solid material and
so we use this as the first step of our
pesticide analysis for concentrates
and really the cannabis concentrates are
much cleaner already than the dry flour
material so we don't use a cleanup
procedure for the concentrates simply a
deleted chute
we run all the samples with a internal
standard and we also carried out a
single point standardization experiment
to verify the absence of matrix effects
on these on these samples so shown in
the picture are a batch of 50 different
concentrates you can see a wide range of
color that we find depending how much
chlorophyll remains in the sample as
well as the other Co extracted
components of the sample
so after extraction and filtering and we
run by the same lc-ms analysis we can
show the same validated method for
cannabis concentrates as well and on
this slide we're showing the single
standard single point standard edition
results showing that we are detecting
spiked pesticides as we expected for
most of the analytes
and on this slide we're showing the
results of our market survey for
cannabis concentrates in this case we
use 48 samples from the Denver market
and we're finding a very high positivity
rate and we think this is due to the
fact that in the cannabis concentrates
the pesticides are actually concentrated
more than than they were in the flower
and then by that fact they are going to
be above the required action limit on
each in each state so it may be more
likely for cannabis concentrates to test
positive for pesticides than the flower
material so in this case we're showing
over 80% positive rate and again paper
no meat oxide pyrethrins or the most
common also michael butanol and some of
the new Nikita knives are also detected
as well
and for comparison in Spokane we looked
at about a hundred samples and this is
again a similar selection of cannabis
concentrates and we found a similar
positive detection rate that we found in
Denver that's over 80 percent testing
positive and again the same pesticides
testing positive that we found in Denver
and I want to call attention especially
to several the several important
compounds in this list which are not
required to be monitored by the states
in particular carbon design so carbon is
emisn antifungal that made the headlines
a few years ago being found in oranges
and orange juice and it has an
antifungal activity so it's no surprise
to find this on cannabis but it's not
actually required to be monitored in any
of the states that we visited or in
Canada either but we found it in about
10% of our samples so this could reflect
a trend among growers to switch to
unlisted pesticides
and
to show the method robustness over a
two-week period and almost a thousand
injections of samples we show that the
instrument performance is very good
and we can measure that by retention
time by peak with iron ratio and signal
intensity and it shows that this method
is well suited to high throughput and
also long-term analysis of pesticides in
cannabis even with these very
complicated samples
so to conclude we found that pesticides
were used in cannabis and fairly widely
we found that our method gave a very
good result in terms of being efficient
to use and sensitive to detect low
levels of pesticides we found that the
cannabis concentrates could be analyzed
by just simple dilute and Shu method and
we found very good lcms robust
performance and we also found that there
could be growers switching to pesticides
that are not in any of the state
monitoring lists so it's important for
States to keep aware of new pesticides
that are not currently being monitored
so inclusion I want to thank our
collaborators all the work that we've
done has been in collaboration with
state certified laboratories since the
product is federally illegal so
especially we worked with members of
trace analytics in Spokane Washington as
well as members from other organizations
as well providing consumables and we
also want to thank your collaborators at
Nordic
and I want to thank all of you in the
audience for your attention and I'd be
happy to answer any questions you may
have
thank you dr. doll for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
once there's many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is can a smaller
sample amount be used and how are the
samples collected
well that's a good question in the
cannabis industry there's a strong
pressure to use smaller samples because
the product is very valuable but in on
the other hand we have to make sure that
the sample is representative and so
typically what the states require is
that sample collector represents the lab
and collects a sample and a
statistically sound sampling procedure
usually that means going to a production
lot and selecting a small sub sample
from a randomly assigned part of the
batch so if we had a 15-pound batch this
collector will select a small sample
from several different places throughout
the batch to ensure that a
representative sample is selected and
depending on the state's rules the
sample might range from 10 or 20 grams
for example and from that larger sample
we would then select an even smaller sub
sample so in the presentation we used a
1 gram sample for the pesticide analysis
in principle there's nothing stopping us
from using a smaller sample because the
instruments are able to detect
pesticides from a smaller amount our for
to to get a good representativeness
typically we use a 1 gram sub sample
and our next question is can I test for
potency be done in the same analysis as
the pesticides
so the potency measurement is quite a
different measurement than the
pesticides the instrumentation is
capable of doing both pesticides and
potency but because of the large
difference in concentration we usually
would do a different dilution to do the
potency measurement so the pesticides
might be present in concentrations as
low as five or ten parts per billion
whereas the cannabinoids might be in
concentrations that are more of you know
several percent up to 20 percent and so
typically even though the
instrumentation could make the
measurement we'd usually need to dilute
the sample more for the potency
measurement and due to some other
factors such as the ease of calibration
we usually recommend running potency by
an LCU v and then dedicating the lc/ms
towards the pesticide measurement
doctors all it looks like we have time
for one more question can you detect
pesticides that are not on the state
required monitoring list so with our
measurement techniques the typical
workflow is to use the mrm mode for
detection and in MRI mode we're
typically starting with a targeted
pesticide list and in our presentation
we are covering a larger list of
compounds than is required by any of the
states and we can certainly add many
more pesticides to those monitoring
lists and in fact we found pesticides in
cannabis samples that were not actually
required to be measured by the states
and this could reflect growers switching
to different pesticides so we certainly
can expand the monitoring list beyond
what the states require
I would like to once again thank dr.
Dahle for his presentation I would also
like to thank laborat for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2018
you will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye